the man walked into our our booth here
our radio booth position high atop the
proceedings is they're getting ready to
be put together and this is pretty sweet
man see good man we're gonna be down in
that that stage right down there in the
corner yeah I just that's amazing that
that's the small video board every time
I come to the stadium I see and are
massive and then Hey look the first time
I saw a game here was the Super Bowl
between Pittsburgh and Green Bay right
and and I was sitting right around like
the 2025 and every single time the play
was over I'd look up and I get a replay
then and then I realized after a while
that I was no longer watching the action
I was watching the game on the on the TV
which is what the idea is why Jerry
Jones had it built did you hear the be
genesis of how that came to know I don't
know the story a Las Vegas act in in Las
Vegas Nevada Jerry and his wife go and
see the why am i God Hernandez Levin had
showing the Eileen D on the great Celine
Dion had a huge screen behind her and
he's just like we should get one of
those for for our new stadium and
another reason why is if we're battling
with people to come to the game we're
battling with their high-definition
screen at home let's put it between the
20s and let's have them watch the game
here with a replay all over do you
remember that first year well all the
talk was all these punts are gonna hit
that well somebody had wanted to do it
right
somebody lit purposefully did it maybe
was in warmup somebody got in a
preseason game somebody purposely tried
to hit it and they did but any rate
we're here we're excited for it let's
get right down to you know I really want
to dig in right now on Lamar Jackson
because that is the guy who I think is
the biggest mystery out of all of these
quarterbacks as to where he goes and
what he can be evaluating evaluate this
guy soup-to-nuts for me going into
Thursday night according to you Daniel
Jeremiah well the the athletic ability
is easy right everybody sees that you
see how explosive he is how dynamic he
is as a runner that's that's all
documented that's there's no question
there's no debate on that as a passer
the good news for Lamar is that it's
trending up each and every year you're
seeing progress
being made there now he's not he's not
there he's got long ways to go there's
some mechanical things I continue I work
like what just with his base and
everything he gets so narrow that
affects his accuracy he's very
comfortable everything inside and
working in there because he's kind of a
flipper I call him he's really a flipper
instead of a thrower he's literally kind
of almost like Mike like the way Vic
threw was just all you know flipping it
and so everything in in between the
hashes he's comfortable driving the ball
outside the hashes it's all over the
place so you've got to continue to work
on that and develop that I've been
saying look you take him his high school
coach changed the offense for his
college coach changed the offense for
him worked out swimmingly is that work
does that's that worked out well yeah I
was waiting for that unless you can't
swim unless you can't swim yes it is so
to me that's what's gonna happen the NFL
level I think he needs to go somewhere
where not only does he need time time
for him to develop I think it'll take a
little bit of time for whoever drafts
him to figure out a way to construct the
offense because they're gonna change
what they're doing the question that we
get all the time is what team fits Lamar
Jackson and I'm like no no you're asking
the wrong question you know you got it
you're gonna have to fit yourself to him
it's not the other way around he's not
fitting himself to you so there's gonna
be some time where you got to kind of
figure that out there in the difference
with him and deshaun Watson is that
DeSean which is further along as a
pastor so even though they changed
things they're with Bill O'Brien to show
him from where he started from with from
a throwing standpoint was just further
head so what a then let's try and locate
teams that might be willing to change
what they do could New England be one of
those absolutely and I think that would
be it kind of in a way would be a total
New England move that we're gonna be
ahead of the curve this is what the
college game is going to be putting out
going forward everybody's running this
offense so this is the most dynamic guy
we've seen run that offense so it's
eventually gonna all trickle up because
all these 37 38 41 year old quarterbacks
are gonna be gone so let's be early on
this trend here and you have some time
with Tom right now no pun intended nice
to be able to work on Lamar and really
kind of be developing another offense
and then all of a sudden New England
unveils that thing a year two years from
now it may not be fun what about New
Orleans
yeah that's another one I think these
college coaches are so interested in
what goes on in college and they spend
so much time studying that that game I
almost think a guy like Sean Payton
would just totally reinvigorating to say
I have so many different things that I
can do that I've wanted to do and
explore and different options and a guy
like the Mark Jackson would give you
that I keep Cincinnati Baltimore New
England the Saints those are the teams
that I think of most when I think and
who do you think might trade back into
the first round to go get him because I
think based on what I'm hearing and the
way that I'm seeing this all set up if
Arizona does not take him in the middle
of the first round yeah he's not gonna
be gotten by then then it's gonna he'll
be in play late Thursday night yeah so
and that's the most likely scenario in
all honesty so who do you think comes
back in and use his draft capital to get
that fifth year we just talked about
that with Matt Miller yeah that that
somebody's gonna want him to get that
fifth year developmental got a year
correct right so the team and I keep
coming back to in that regard is you
look at what they've done in the past is
Baltimore you know remember the Flacco
year they moved all the way back and
then they I believe they moved back up a
little bit to Joe so there was some
maneuvering they're not afraid to move
up and down the board and where they're
kind of situated right now almost if
they want to go with a position other
than quarterback you look at you know
maybe a tight end a wide receiver
although wide receiver you might cross
that off the list now with Willie Snead
all the guys they really I mean it's not
like Willie Snead costly Amy Watkins
every time I hear that it like well Dez
is gonna be out cuz Willie Snead yeah I
just think the numbers now when you look
at the numbers that they have it's not
it's not as pressing of a need but
you're looking for an interior offensive
lineman you're looking for a tight end
to me that's a situation where you could
trade back get some extra picks maybe
you take a you know Hayden Hearst you
slide back four or five spots and then
you use some of that extra capital
you've got to come back in and get your
quarterback in the March acts all right
now let's talk about let's take a
60-second break and when we come back I
want to talk about which teams you think
I'm gonna trade up for a quarter okay
cool and what you're here cuz I mean how
long last night I had dinner with you
and Mae out last night and you did what
you just did right there yeah which is
look down in your phone literally every
two minutes you want you want to know
what yes it is yeah I do because last
time we last time asked this question
our number one of Ian Rapoport he gave a
very cryptic
answer but then we started finding out
how he's he's got a bad charging
situation in his hotel room yeah walking
around with them no nice no case on the
phone he's commando he's going commando
with his cell phone which dangerous
thing for an information man okay I'm
gonna get show you the phone who it's
from
in the text won't you read the text
first and I'll let you say who it's from
Ian was not up for playing this game
that's right there
that tie you have on it really looks
nice mom so so mama Jeremiah is is
periscope well I don't know if she's
periscoping right yeah that she is the
way you can see it who knows don't know
you could see it right likes a tie by
the way
love it how how 21st century is it to
say mama Jeremiah is periscoping and we
all know what the hell the original band
name of Mama's in the pocket so there
you go mama Jeremiah is periscoping
which is oh my god I almost went with
the bullfrog and all that sort of is we
come back in 60 seconds I want to know
everything that's in that cell phone
that will tell tell somebody about
what's gonna happen with a team trading
up and Brockman is desperate to hear the
words Patriots for Rosen yes in the
worst way desperate I don't know how
that's gonna happen and unless you drop
this scenario okay that's in 60 seconds
on the Rich Eisen show live from AT&T
Stadium or on occasion enough you can
hear it I hear it through my headsets
the occasional jackhammering yes I'm
here to do okay that's what's going on
here they're they're bolting the stadium
together or hopefully the stage
all right we're back here live on the
Rich Eisen show radio network we're also
available on our app where you can
listen to us absolutely anywhere you hit
the listen live button you can also vote
on our poll question there and go down a
video worm hole Apple App Store Google
Play hit the link at the top of our
Twitter handle at Rich Eisen show where
you can also take in this show via
periscope Jeremiah is clearly doing
right now so waving hello hi mom like
Tom Brady right like that another
segment here at Daniel Jeremiah on the
Rich Eisen show live from inside AT&T
stadium who is trading up for a
quarterback Buffalo the latest stuff
that you hear is is you hear Buffalo in
five for a long time and now it's a
Denver yeah what Denver and then now
it's hey you know if maybe there's a
chance they get to for maybe there is a
chance that Cleveland gets out there
which I don't agree with I think if
you're Cleveland you should stick and
pick and get it really win it now but
yes they've been doing this forever like
that's let's just get some blue chip
players so I don't know that that's it
that's floating out there so for
whatever that's worth but I definitely
I'll be surprised if Buffalo's first
pick is at number 12 I'll buy you dinner
better very affordable well last night
may Ocwen he picked up a check says that
never pay for it I've never bought with
Mike he won't let me I don't try very
hard at least I made the reach was a big
number you know I just so you know
Brockman it was a nice large number yeah
a whopping fine number as they say in
dr. Seuss world
I made the reach Daniel verbalized I can
I you know like okay the verb okay I
made the actual legitimate reach for
though here's the thing though here's
the strategy you got to wait till it's
it's grabbed because if you make the
offer before it's grabbed then it's fair
game you kind of got to jump in there
but he's not gonna grab it and then you
ask and then go oh here you go right so
I wait for the grab make the offer and
I'm clean it's like the catch roll you
waited for him to have complete
possession of I survived the ground and
a football move hit the check did not
survive the table I like it so Buffalo
moves up from 12 yep and they use
obviously there are other pick to do
that right yeah what about the scenario
of
getting up to the giant spot who can do
that you know I laid out the the thing
we talked about on the show that one day
about a three-team or with with the
Colts ticket potentially work I think it
makes so much sense I don't know why so
how will just give me give me give me
how that would possibly work a
three-team trade in the NFL jury yeah
it's in first of all I had
Charlie casually called the league
totally legal okay and totally do it
happens in the NBA all the time but the
Giants here's the problem they don't
wanna go back to 12
so they it's the third team as the Colts
they go to six the Colts have been
looking to get a bunch of picks because
the roster so bad right they go back to
12 Buffalo it the way it all kind of
works the Giants I had it when I did the
numbers on the chart would have to just
give up a fifth round pick and they were
getting a haul of picks to go from two
to six cuz that's it that's a big number
in terms of but the Giants would've had
to cough up a fifth of their own a fifth
that they would trade number two and a
five of their own and they were getting
a haul of picks you know which was
number six I think they might even have
got the second section runner from
Buffalo and then would have gotten the
call and the Colts the Colts were
getting a bunch of those twos as well as
you know going to twelve so they were
getting some action and there was really
no picks for the next year you could do
it math wise with the chart which of
course you got to overpay a little bit
with with quarterbacks but there's a way
that it could work for those three teams
so you'd have to say that again that
that deal is struck right now as we're
sitting would have to but it has yeah
you have to see who's actually been
selected yes to see if the one that the
bills want add to it would be a to what
we think they would be comfortable with
either one Allen or I give the give
Daniel Jeremy give give Brockman his
patrons getting Rosen's okay here's a
scenario so if you if you see those
three quarterbacks go and there's
potential for one to slide and that's
Rosen I don't think they can get all the
way out there in the top five okay but
once you get past five right if the
Colts don't get out
they stick and pick roll Quan Smith is a
name that you hear they're the the Bucs
are not taking a quarterback the Bears
are not taking a quarterback now you get
to the Niners and the Raiders they're
not taking quarterbacks but I would
think 9 and 10 you've got relationships
there you've got a relationship
obviously with John Lynch that just did
the Garoppolo thing so maybe this is the
turnaround you
go ahead and come up there and go get
Rosen there or it's the Gruden situation
where that roster needs some help in
Oakland as well he could amass some
picks and go back there so the 910 I
guess we call the turn or whatever would
be that's this area the sweet spot got
to get ahead of Miami's inside the
division to go get Josh Rosen that's how
what does that cost them there's well
they're two ones right two ones and the
43rd overall something all I would say
is I think the the 49ers you could say
they got over a little bit on the
Garoppolo the one you owe me one yeah
come on I don't think it works but
that's what you're selling what you're
selling Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show let's because we're on in South
Florida on the Rich Eisen show a radio
network there's a lot of talk about that
I'm gonna go Marlins there for a second
whoa no no that's on HBO tonight with
Jeter and Bryant Gumbel on fuse I know
nothing it's oh my gosh yeah he tainted
where he did did Jeter call he called
Gumbel like mentally soft or something
like yeah that weak minded oh yeah and
cuz cuz Gumbel's accusing him of tanking
and he says he's not tanking he expects
them to compete not you know contend
that if I'm talking dolphins what is the
deal with Tannehill do they want to move
on from him and and and fake Baker
Mayfield or Rosen would they trade up in
order to move on from Ryan tan
everything that I kind of hear is just I
don't see them really being aggressive
to move up if one were to fall to them
then maybe that 11 would go in that
direction as a chance they go in that
direction and they need a lot more yeah
but here's the thing though like if you
were if you were 100% committed to Ryan
Tannehill are you doing this much work
on all these quarter by the way and
aren't you coming out and saying hey at
least to somebody locally and that get
the word gets out that we were very
happy with Ryan Tannehill we're gonna
try and get somebody to help him out
we're not having to replace it but that
hasn't happened so give me another one
one more quarterback new young team that
you think Arizona's gonna be fun
why wouldn't they take Lamar Jackson 215
do you think that they might take Mason
Rudolph in the middle of the first
that's too high that coffee's a little
rich for me but
I can't see it there I would think you'd
be in a trade back scenario Lamar
Jackson I could get behind I could I can
understand that
at 15 yeah I mean I still it's higher
than I have him created but I it's a
gamble it's a risk but man I get it
there's a huge payoff me overspending or
overreaching for a quarterback does not
matter yeah if the guy plays well the
same thing again the Jets overlooked the
Jets overspent to get from 6 to 3
there's no question that they overspent
if they get their guy you can't
overspend they was not they would not
have overspent to go from 6 to 3 if they
didn't go for the Fugazi Kirk Cousins
yeah and by that I don't mean that
Cousins isn't a good quarterback
I don't please never go on there no one
there so they took gold by looking at
him and the Colts knew ok they might not
get Kirk Cousins or we don't think
they're getting Kirk Cousins let's ask
for that other two yeah all that said it
doesn't matter that the Jets have
overspent for them nobody gotta get it
three starts winning divisions and
titles it's funny because there is so
much pressure on the Jets to get the
quarterback thing right but I'm telling
you there's gonna be as much pressure on
the Giants for the guy that could
potentially pass on yeah is there is on
the Jets on who they potentially pick
because if you're the Giants and you
pass on say it's it's darn old or Rosen
and they go to the Jets in the same
building and they anchor that roster for
the next 12 to 15 years and you spend a
decade trying to find the replacement
for Eli Manning not a good situation
erect damn alright so who's in the chute
for you that you can't wait to get see
get drafted just like a story that like
this is what this kid deserves or yeah I
mean there's there's so many of those in
this draft I'm kind of curious I like
when we get as you know me I kind of
like the guys are a little bit from the
small schools right a guy like Dallas
got hurt from South Dakota State the
tight end who's just a really really
good football player late one or two is
probably we're gonna see his his name I
just one-handed catch is that maybe the
best catch this year of anybody in the
whole draft I've seen a lot of mocs
sending him the New Orleans yep I think
New Orleans Carolina and Jacksonville
are three teams you can keep an eye on
for tight end okay and that's a fun one
what was the one that on the way back
from dinner last night
that you already have all lined up with
a with a song or something oh yeah we
got a receiver from limestone limestone
yeah where is limestone I haven't I
haven't got there yet but I haven't got
there no I've done is Vincent Smith I
believe his name okay I've evaluate my
bad notes at limestone college limestone
universe I want to say it's definitely
sounds like a college I'm stone college
and Gaffney South what is their mascot
because we were hoping it was the
Cowboys Bernard yeah you can't go you
can't go Glen Campbell on that one but
if limestone is becomes the cowboy
that's the story that we like a
limestone Cowboys can we live our ball
real quick can we speak that into
existence
I don't know Jerry's probably gonna be
strolling around here soon enough
hey Jerry go get the limestone just so
he could I would go we kind of bullied
the Vikings into taking more it's boring
here can we do it one more time a hawk
will dive under the table and and by the
way last night
Brockman bringing up the parrot he
understands Mayock understands that
there's some all sorts of silliness
right up day three so like he's now he's
accepted it he's got a limit he's got a
limit got a credit limit so cuz last
year with the orangutan making the day
three picks for the Colts and we kept
going back and back and like four or
five picks and the first time he thought
it was funny second time humours third
time not so much then the fourth time is
just like so some kids life dream is
being realized Grover and it's over to
ranga tang that's gross he got really
pissed on behalf of Grover's for LA TV
so of course that only sent our
producers in the NFL Network truck back
to her even more
they created like that graphic baseball
card for the orangutan like had oily
hips or something was amazing
long story short so last night he said
he will give the parrot two pics before
he's had an it's a parrot getting more
than one I'm a parrot as you know repeat
so I would imagine it the parrot get
it's a it's a two flight to pick
situation before Mayock goes off
parrot here's a question if I gave you
access in Tampa to the the trainer for
the parrot and you could get the parrot
to say one thing - Mike what would it be
Oh watching tape I do like that
quicker than fast yeah quicker than fast
heavy waist bender yeah meatball
meatball said Bubba but it's a two
flight situation for the parrot before
he gets ejected from mike Mayock swirled
DJ i will see you later on we're doing
down here all suited and booted and I'll
see you down there in about a half an
hour great time DJ great time yeah thank
you you're back in here back in mama
Jeremiah's play did you get you that
time there might have been a box that
arrived with a couple ties good mama's
boy Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience